what's the white stuff on the bait
what's that white powder that's coke bro
hopefully
well the head is flat enough to just
take a line right off that baby's head
these guys
you guys that's my newborn son we're
just kidding man it's a comedy podcast
yeah we got you don't send a picture
like this then if you don't want to get
clown
your flat baby ass head
[Music]
the other day i saw a
[Music]
yeah
how was that how much was it though
first of all huh it was 80. i had a
coupon it was actually 68.
no did you use a groupon or to a psychic
no this is just a uh any psyche that's
giving out coupons i'd be a little
alarmed about it it was 15 off good deal
so what'd she say what's your reveal
[Music]
she was talking mostly about dating
[Music]
uh she had some like actually a lot of
geographical type of stuff where she
thought like
plate shifting that sort of stuff stuff
that's out of my control she said
plate shifting like uh tectonics so you
went to a jeep a geologist psychic
dude
what does that have to do with
what's going on with you she's like yeah
so the plates and that means you're also
going to meet a girl yeah it sounds
pretty general yeah yeah
if you guys are done being mean i'll
talk to somebody that cares about her
was that the 15 off
she's talking about the geology she
talked about your dating life a little
bit yes you talked about dating just
about love future she calls them is it
recording are we recording now yeah man
we are okay
because i just want to let you know i've
been getting messages about
like you
like like playboy bunnies are hitting me
up but i know they don't want to talk to
me
who the hell's little butterfly
i don't know i feel like she was a
blonde with big boobs so she said little
butterfly says hello
you're supposed to be like i don't know
what they want from me and you're
supposed to be the middle man in the
theo's heart yeah like i'm your message
i can't tell you that deal
little butterfly huh yeah i'm not saying
her name i i don't i don't remember but
she that's her alias like huh like you
know what you should do steve what you
should be is like you know what you
should do is you should
i know what theo likes so
you should do it with me first yeah this
is what road managers do on the road
with the big bands
without me test driving it and put a
winky face i also had
they really want to date you so i've had
like extensive messages like steve like
i'm like supposed to help like i'm like
their coat like how how are we going to
do this steve can you help me with theo
and i'm like what do you want for you
yeah hey steve i don't know what to tell
you you know what this tells me if the
top of the morning steve i'm sorry if
theo goes to jail he's still gonna get a
lot of he's gonna be like one of those
oh he's going to be like your
nightstalker yeah yeah yeah yeah chick's
going to be going to jail to visit him
for conjugal visits and stuff oh yeah
they love you dude you're going to do
well they love you when you eventually
go to prison you're going to do well
hey you know how last week you're like
who's going to go into this
you know how last week you're like who's
gonna go in the military well this week
it's who's gonna go to prison you win
this week no no
statistically i think half of eric
okay and we're back ladies and gentlemen
dude that's just the way that tectonic
plates crumble
she told him bro
by the way i got a lot of love this week
i think all the king and distinct people
reached out and i appreciate it what'd
they say you got love yeah yeah they
were a lot of like don't listen to the
haters it was a lot of overwhelming
positivity i also got that yeah and i
realize i'm the nate dog of podcasts how
so cause i go on the other tracks make
them hot but nobody listens to my apples
[Laughter]
[Music]
he had a sickness i thought yeah huh
yeah yeah
yeah he had cancer or something yeah but
that's still like getting murdered
they're not watching you your numbers
aren't good
no no no it's not it's it's it's a sad
situation your name you know but i love
my fans but give him some pointers how
does he increase his uh you need theo
yeah dude your goal your goal point
you want to disappoint love okay i'm
just going to like there's just a lot of
wild energy out there right now man
there's people in the park that caught a
guy in a park by my apartment with a gun
what bro well how's your house in uh in
tennessee because the floods did the
psychic did she tell your house that's
the plates look oh yeah i'm not
uh are you worried about your house no
what if it just
who's staying there right now i gotta
have somebody stay in there or i got
you're like a cousin 12 plants and i got
a guy going to check on it two times a
week and you have house insurance so if
it did float away you're good let it go
baby let it go but sometimes that
insurance don't cover that kind of stuff
no but you know what i mean
they think it does but they get real
specific
they don't cover a certain type of yeah
like all this [ __ ] it should cover yeah
it's in a fine print yeah we don't cover
that yeah like like out in california if
anybody breaks the name cedric we don't
cover that
it's weird i think it's real special
and there's like a shading of like you
know the different types of black
oh dang you got charcoal we don't cover
that bro
now we cover bruised peach
but we don't cover charcoal bubba
but um
and you in your area where you guys are
you know what i'm saying
what about that
what do you mean my area i'm talking
about korea okay yeah i don't want to
say it
but yeah uh you guys are used to having
to move your houses a lot right the
house has floated away kind of just
well i don't know i haven't been to
korea in a long time i don't know how
that works but you can find koreans
close your eyes and ask your heart
you'll know at the end
in the philippines in vietnam the house
is float away yeah and they just rebuild
it so literally
you really are you should be that kind
of guy
what kind of guy
just ready to move
that rebuild
yeah
you think that eric
welcome back to candace
we are talking about
houses floating away i don't know do you
think who's most likely to be able to
handle if their house floats away out of
this who's going to rebuild steve for
sure i guess yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you got those bamboo
hands baby
yeah
i do need to upgrade though you're right
i do need like who can move with a
duffel bag and backpack and be cool
that's me exactly
yeah he can get the hot plate yeah you
know what i'm saying that's in your
nature you're going to still need to do
this
for my black butt well oh well i see i
thought you just got rid of it and we
kind of moved no we said didn't we talk
about it we could get it and then we
kind of just put it in a shoe box or
something that means he kept it around
that means you still have it yeah dude
it's in my closet that relationship is
linked
see if they'll do something to your
assistant living man
well is that what do you mean by that
the place you stay at is it an assisted
living or no no it's rent control that's
why i haven't moved it's rent control oh
yeah
but i don't let you guys meet up
downstairs to play at night or like
like uh like is there a bingo night no
yeah not bingo he doesn't live in an old
folks home yeah that community seems
like they would all get together and
like have some pudding
checkers i saw two people out front
watering the same plant together
that's kind of senior
so you all been there everyone's been
there theo forgot he forgot i'll get a
one bedroom next time i think
that's the body part
he's amazing about your little assistant
this [ __ ] was so broke yeah you
know what i mean and now he over here
you might wanna smoke a cigar in his
face [ __ ]
no no
that's what it's like living down yeah
how does it feel
or something there i have a room
i have windows
how's your tent steve how's your tent in
korea town i do sleep on a sleeping bag
do you oh yeah don't you guys sleep on
like uh cheers here we go you guys let
me close my eyes but you don't talking
about you sleep on a sleeping bag on the
mat on the mattress i have the coleman
sleeping bag on the oh yeah
yeah
yeah that's scissor brothers money
coming in here all right
is that from theo the thirst trap
himself trying on the ufc broadcast yeah
and he did it this can be a [ __ ]
banger dana can't thank you enough bro
hashtag fight night
every fight
he's just so thirsty to get on the ufc
right look every fight it's not
dude i've never been to a fight i would
love to go to this dude step closer to
being rogan that's what he's trying to
do
i'll do all the things your brother
could have done for you
just say that if you want have you seen
bob have you seen bob i did i saw him at
lunch and stuff yeah we went to dinner
night lunch but it's all lunch when
you're at your age
and uh
all right we went to
yeah we went to night lunch had a good
time we talked about you asked how you
were doing really is he is he proud of
stevie now that steve's kind of blowing
up he said he's heard he's doing well
that's what he said
i heard he's wow that's pretty general
all right he didn't even acknowledge his
recent success
well i'm not you're making it seem no he
did thank me for you know for helping
out and being you know thanks i promise
and all of us for helping you out and
giving you some you know getting you out
of the facility or whatever and being a
part of your life man that's important i
think upgrade to a one bedroom there you
go did you think no i could i think i
could yeah don't burn on the ground
eric if you had a sibling
[Laughter]
you're about to hit up dick's sporting
goods get kimchi don't burn on the grill
a lot of people out there need help man
yeah i'm one
well i can help you out with better
health i try some i think i'm gonna try
something else please okay well for some
people yeah i do i do what i can man
listen it's not a christ line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
securely online quit talking to your
friends around the water cooler about
your problems bro talk to a professional
it's worldwide all right yeah all right
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is also available
available better help they want you to
start living a better life today living
more happiness having more happiness
right now be happy yup so many people
have been using better help they're
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states so if you do
counseling or you're lcsw or something
or
anything nra whatever this podcast is
sponsored by better help and king and
the sting listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s that's right visit
betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s
oh you know i've taken these bubby i
have two daddy have you oh they get it
you're popping in the bedroom you got
two kids i bet you have huh yep thanks
to bluetooth bluetooth is a unique
online server that delivers the same
active ingredients as virga and cialis
oh yeah it's chewable daddy it's
chewable bluetooth is an online
prescription service so no visits to the
doctor office no awkward conversations
no wait in line the pharmacy shifts
right to your door oh yeah hard me up
hard me up get blue in the face trying
to get hard baby bluetooth tablets are
made in the u.s of a and preparing ship
direct so it's cheaper
oh i'm trying so if you could benefit
from a little extra confidence in the
sack come on man yes
visit blue.com
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
to receive your first month free i thank
bluetooth for being part of king of the
sting yeah michael hardman stay hard
little butterfly come and look above the
crib
when did you move i will
i mean in the future
how would you say that yeah because
she's always wanted you to move now
you're just going you don't have to
bring that hey time stamp that
i'm saying no seriously
dude one two three flooding you'll be
back there and see that's the thing if
you i would let the lord move you like
he does like the nature of your culture
yes
yeah i think it's time and then maybe
get a car in the future huh maybe get a
little yeah a little toyota corolla
i think i could do it maybe corolla
side of the freeway yeah i'm going to
calabasas and the sheriff
sure or get that senior what's that
senior wheeler that they have out there
nick senior wheeler
golf cart thing
you know what i'm talking about no he
should get the tricycle you know the
three you know what i mean with the two
no i'm not doing that
that's a slingshot yeah two in the front
one in the back though yeah that's the
one i'm talking about hoes you getting
that thing stevie what's this one called
no you need a motorcycle won't be about
the feeling the honey's like the
motorcycles they don't like that no oh
there it is that's that hitter
that's a walker
right there
yeah yeah which one's that little thing
you should just get a camper bring up
that slingshot yeah steve's just get a
camper and just roll around with that
little boy trap on the front dude stevie
for reals if you like the sling shot
i'll i can hook you up what's wrong with
this huh i'll cool like a fish coin trap
i said
oh i thought you said koi fish like a
like a fish trap oh i can't see steve
dude yeah that thing is yeah yeah that's
buttercream
look at that
i can't drive stick shift no i don't
know
who's how much are one of those i i
steve do you even have a license
oh that's a problem
yeah see we're wasting we're not wasting
our time you're a great guy you have a
california id you don't even have a
license i do have a license yeah you
actually drew a picture
i've had a license the whole time you
have all these handlers here that guy
ron or whatever
yeah where's your handler you stopped
coming that's him driving that car right
there can we zoom in on that guy
he's my friend this whole dude is your
friend no i mean
[Laughter]
taking
[Laughter]
15 more years he had you
you sell this thing once theo was born
[ __ ] did you get that
is that a v8 no it's a v4 but i'm
drinking v8
that's the commercial your dad looks
like that my dad did look like that but
he died but he did look like that all
right your dad is dead too huh
yeah dude hey theo dead dad bro that
could be our podcast
[Laughter]
and wait and then you you get this the
the cyclist with theo and stevie's when
the psychic is going to sit in the other
chair
she'll be just like you know
channeling their dads you know what i
mean
you think your dads are having a podcast
wherever they are
i'll produce it
yeah were you there mid to late 90s i
was alive yeah i remember did he did he
look like you feel because you don't
really look like your mom i've seen your
mom in person he looked my dad didn't
look like any of us
would not anymore you couldn't tell at
that point
there's a certain point when you get old
that like knows nobody looks like you
and your ears get big your nose it's all
weird but when you see younger pictures
of him did it look like you i don't
think so oh i wish we had a picture of
it almost honestly i'm not even joking
he had more like your kind of skin tone
a little bit like yours really i'm not
do you think you're a little asian too
i wouldn't be shocked man
my dad was real quiet you're not asian
down there though i heard huh you're not
asian down there baby where'd you hear
this from that athlete jeremiah said
there's something there's something the
biggest penis in the comedian community
you have the biggest one that's a lie oh
german he said he's like that's sweetie
it's a hot tape okay what is this is
this
no this is
a sandwich wait but
how is this a dick explain it to me like
visualize it for me yeah that's that
chunk light yeah dude that's what you
and why we have that chunk light that
star kiss chunk like
what are you talking about bobby
yeah bobby's closer is him showing his
dick isn't it have you seen his penis
yeah dude it's dark we all have the
crazy thing is you have to see it he
shows it to you so many times you have
to because you have you seen it a few
times have you seen it he's shown you
huh oh yeah yeah i've seen it i always
tell him to put a quarterback so i can
get some scale
[Laughter]
i just i need to know yeah i need to
know like where am i where is it be
honest how big is how big is it yeah you
remember when you were kids don't you
yeah we were kids though it hasn't
changed
so tell us what it was like then just
grab it if you don't mind for a second
we're about to go to commercial break
anyway i just remember it was dark how
about this
the three you guys i think should have
to describe it since y'all have seen it
and we'll i know yeah let's go around
the room who did best
it's like a tan little earthworm
you know it's like a thicker more than
that even more than that yeah with like
uh that's surrounded by like
forestry yeah like a thick bush think of
a like a worm like a like almost a burnt
worm
oh it is burnt
it is burnt my friend but like
but wearing like a ski cap
yeah like he's about to rob a liquor
store for the insurance money that he he
owns a liquor store but he's gonna rob
it yeah
you know what i mean
a little racial but yeah
beef jerky it looks like a burnt piece
of beef jerky yeah yeah dark yeah
i remember it looked like it and
it looked like it had worked at the
dewey decimal system but then it got
into drugs yeah
it was a librarian it's been through
some [ __ ] like it had been living in an
apple yes
but it didn't come out for dope but an
apple that somebody was using as a bomb
[Laughter]
smoked it somebody was
you know one of those apple bongs
yeah well his bit wouldn't be funny if
he had just this giant dick right then
there's no does he really get naked well
that's like eric i'm used to you know
eric andre does that yeah he's hilarious
and he's got a giant enormous dude and
he tucks in he tucks it and i was i was
i was in australia with him we just
happened to be at the same time i went
to his show and then so he's doing this
thing where he tucks but i'm standing
behind backstage like it's so big that
he had a tail
how big is that whoa man don't do that
with your hand
it's not a
sandwich bro explain what this is you're
eating a super hamburger like it's like
12 inches
off the person but they eat everything
in their culture bro it's like you can
that's why they're used to that
what do you mean because why else would
you say
unless in your dna of your hand dna that
you or your people have helped you know
you're doing this but you're like this
steve and then he goes to the different
sizes of like this yeah you know what i
mean like this is the different sizes
this is the girth no this is the this is
the girth yeah this is the girl you
don't want to do this okay but is this
the dick here no the dick that's from
here okay so you've disappeared from
this is the nuts and now it's hold on
this is better nuts okay they're better
nicer pictures but then you can't be
like when the dick is just as big as the
nuts that's
how does that work that's like i'm sorry
so it's this you know what i mean
yeah yeah sorry all right what do you
got nick
you get a king of their stinger yeah
it's getting a little homoerotic over
here yeah what's up guys this is eddie
from chicago coming at you with the king
of the sting it big eddie it's this uh
crate challenge thing that i just keep
seeing all over my feet i'm sure you've
seen it where they're stacking up these
milk crates and they're walking across
up it with a big group of people around
them they're falling on their back their
neck it's honestly amazing i love it
but that's probably just because it's
not anything but the taliban or kova
coming up in my feed
but yeah that's my question for you guys
king understing it the crate challenge
could you do it is it good for uh our
society let me know
who could do it in here
i was just saying you're you're right i
don't know what it what is that you're
limber you've never seen the crate
challenge no what is that i feel like
we're too big yeah yeah good crowd you
know holds 50 pounds yeah here's
somebody right here here it is
it's kind of like the hood olympics
where are they getting these crates oh
they're milk crates they're milk crates
is there a crate company
oh you're gonna make a statement now
here we go like shikari richardson
well he pulled out a book
is that hard to do huh okay
okay
[Music]
oh i could do that for sure i think a
lot more people are doing it than not
doing it but we just see the people
[ __ ] up the people that are falling
uh it's great when they eat [ __ ] okay so
is it what causes this for though this
is like the this is like the ice bucket
challenge right isn't it for like it's
for no sickle cell oh you know that ice
bucket it didn't sol it didn't cure any
of those people they poured cold water
like it was for ms or whatever
they don't know
they raised a lot of money
stevie could do it i could do that i
think i could do it yeah i could do it
if you put cold water on yourself i
could do that yeah you ain't going to
get rid of ms man i feel like everybody
in here could do pretty well at it
here's one right here an officer did it
see this did he fall and kill himself by
accident
oh this is how we train in those afghan
cops right here yeah
afghan army training
that's what the two trillion dollars
went
we got
this half of children over here [ __ ]
biden's milk center
they want this cop to fall oh yeah they
do that guy's all talking [ __ ]
oh
what oh
holy
stop it for a second
this would have been crazy though he
falls his gun goes off and kills
somebody and then they're like another
car
nightmare it would have just been
it would have been so stupid you know
what i mean like it's like what are you
doing two more weeks of peaceful proof
yeah yeah yeah eight more weeks of
winter
every time a cop killed a black dude
it's eight more weeks of winter man
cause they one weeks a cove and every
time the cop kills a black dude
so stupid
but it could be realistic man we need to
look at a chart i don't know about this
crazy
this is about anything the olympics put
out i'd rather watch this than that
look at that
somebody got seriously injured how many
crates do you need do you think to do
that well it's easy to know that
i need to open a crate company now yeah
my boy my boy bradley martin did it and
people were not pleased you should get
some king in the sting white people ruin
everything
my boy bradley did i mean i mean
there was a goal for people i don't
think to do real well i mean like 20
craters yeah bradley did it with weights
and then someone said i can feel when
these crates call me the n-word
damn they're doing this everywhere you
don't have to get black guys there he is
right here oh what's this little honey
right here though yeah a little crate
honey
[Music]
oh he's ju
no [ __ ] no
is that at that gym y'all go to brendan
man
could you do it brenden yeah no you
could do that brandon yeah yeah you
could so you're supposed to go to the
top and then do something no you don't
have he that's just his spin on it
people just keep stepping it up yeah a
lot of people were complaining because
he was on flat ground instead of grass
like in the hood
too
yeah that's a dicey thing complaining
yeah man you're his you're his size you
could do it yeah but that's a big
difference doing it in grass
i'm into everything i don't get this at
all
it's gonna be gone by next week
is this a new thing yeah yeah it just
got popping like a week ago and what if
you can make it across it cures als or
whatever
now that would be awesome they get a guy
with als to start
get him over it and he has to
concentrate so much that the als just
goes away because he got to keep himself
steady i don't know this is jealous they
can't hold us
well there's a lot of there's a lot of
things on tick-tock and all that kind of
stuff to go viral
uh like you know just trends yeah just
like training yeah yeah yeah yeah but
this one's getting bigger because people
again because that was a king it had
mike right here it's better than the
olympics
i'm stinging it
right in a field chin nick nick and chin
small guy in the back i got a king of
the stinger for you guys coming from
canada chew meatball yeah taking the
teeth out while making sweet sweet love
oh
oh
too yeah those are nice dude my uncle he
said when he come indoors he set his
teeth right there on the windowsill and
like relax a little bit teeth was for
outdoors only all teeth
so he's saying just taking your time
i think he said well he's making out
speak sweet love
that [ __ ]
i'm the only iguana in this [ __ ]
come on
most of my sexual experience is a prayer
mostly in the beginning
that she don't get pregnant
we're praying that you get it you're
praying you get it up
yeah i'll even play samuel l jackson to
my penis on my phone you know
god just to get him hyped up you know
i'm just getting motivated yeah we gotta
dear lord brother theo
needs to uh
admirably today so if we can uh get the
congregation together of the kingdom
congregation my people hard lizard
tongue huh
[Laughter]
do you have that kind of move i feel
like you could hide on a woman's body
she wouldn't even know you're there yeah
i feel like i think i could do that yeah
i could i like to look down there yeah
just hide nothing on a woman's body
did you just sneak into women's houses
when you were young no we me and bob
never got girls when we were younger but
what did you do it's always you and bob
he jerked off a lot
you know he jerked off
we couldn't get we went to church camp
but yeah okay did you have like
it was your time and then he would leave
no no he'd be in his room i'd be in my
room are you in your room
all right man i'm gonna jerk off yeah
that's what we did wow did you know he
was doing it when you were doing it yeah
he didn't get girls in high school i'm
sorry to say he got girls when he did
comedy yeah but i remember a girl coming
like
he was out of rehab and there was a girl
from his rehab
that i saw i've never seen a girl in his
bedroom and i remember her walking out
i'm like oh damn bob's has a girl in his
room got a little fly in his trap were
your parents okay if you had girls over
we never did
so they'd have to deal with it but what
about you just did in the story
yeah he didn't have one in the story
was she attractive yeah she was pretty
hot dude yeah i was impressed i'm like
oh i was proud of him did you go talk to
him no i didn't [ __ ] block no i let him
do it you go smell the sheets afterwards
no no
i'm just trying to figure their dynamic
man but there was a woman in here that's
the line
that was hilarious to me that was the
first one i see
yeah i mean i feel like that's you know
you guys don't feel like that's crazy to
smell some man's sheets who's been
possibly spending time with somebody
cares about i don't know what he likes
to do man yeah
first time a girl came it depends on
who's on top though
like yeah you don't smell your brother's
ass yeah yeah if she's on the bottom
then yeah you want to you smell the [ __ ]
who's sweating during sex man you guys
are freaking out
you don't over exert yourself doing some
sex
so you just no you're not you never
sweat during sex i'm that calm lover on
that wim hof daddy you know what i'm
saying
holds his breath yeah he's a slow lover
too that's what you tell you don't want
to get he don't over exert himself so
feel one of those
wait i'm the one heart rate under 80.
you like to get her like this sneak up
on your back
[Laughter]
she's like can i just start already
should i get into it man but he quick he
got that koi blood in him this little
guy yeah i'm a quick one he quick bro he
got that sardine in him yeah
yeah jackhammer
you got that sardine baby you got that
roe egg in you what's this gentleman
saying his belly button is big enough to
do this guy this guy also he's got to be
nice belly button he's got the same body
height on that belly button dude don't
do that don't let's body shame him dude
we're not body shaped
same body type as my first girlfriend
beach games this is the bryan cowan
special spike ball
gang ghost bonus
[Music]
oh this game
what game is that oh that's it the crate
challenge she said beach games king
understand it uh yeah why not
yeah i'm waiting to see that if you want
to play some beach go in the water fire
away man do you do beach games do you
guys doing no i like going in the water
yeah i'm a water guy the beast can't get
tan and i have to get in the water like
a seal man
not me you ever get that big cheeks in
the water
no man i don't get harpooned out there
you know bugs
i show these [ __ ] once dude
and i'm dinner for an inuit
you know look man right now out in uh
there's a lot of flooding out out right
now out in the central east and that can
mean that you know you could have uh
water could get into your dang air
conditioning system or in the valley
here calabasas your ac might shut down
yeah because of heat i mean there's all
different types of things that can
happen you have a bad refrigerator or
anything american
home shield
members they got you covered they'll
replace it service fees limitations
exclusions apply c plan for
from hvac systems and plumbing to
kitchen appliances their plans help
protect parts of up to 23 essential home
systems and appliances that's right like
smart watches flat screen tvs and more
they there there are so many options uh
roof leak repair pool and spa coverage
coverage available no matter how old
your system appliances are exclusive
fifty dollars off for the listeners of
king and the state right right now to
celebrate 50 years of providing
homeowners peace of mind american home
shield is letting you take fifty dollars
off their most comprehensive plans ever
go to ahs.com
k-a-t-s
now to save fifty dollars it's
ahs.com cats for 50 off any plans
service fees limitations and exclusions
apply see plan for details american home
shield be sure with the shield
i say seed a lot of time or semen i'll
say semen or seed
you get them confused no i just that's
what i prefer man and sometimes right on
a diet man you get bloated though oh now
that's a good point you feel me if
you're looking for a way to ease the
bloating you're not alone man i'm with
you guys in fact two out of three
americans live with digestive comfort
fart all the time man and it's not good
you got them poop issues that's why seed
seed is working to change all that poop
issues yeah dog yeah man they got two in
one probiotic prebiotic all right they
got you covered man for your gut and
what do you got to do inject it or how
do you even now you just follow these
little pills man start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com cats use the
code cats to redeem 20 off your first
month of seeds daily synbiotic that's
seeds.com cats use the code cats that's
right visit seed.com k-a-t-s use code
k-a-t-s to redeem 20
off your first month of seeds daily
synbiotic that's seeds.com cats and use
code cats you think you know probiotics
you're actually wrong
thanks to seeds
someone sent in cats in the wild on the
king of the sting facebook group they
said the diamond punched some brendan
into the theater
i like the guy on the right that's a
beautiful haircut dude
damn is that guy hitler's descendant
[Laughter]
yeah it's uh
dustin's friend uh
pablito i'm like a bank robber yeah dude
and he's pretty funny on twitter
actually
habalito pablito or cody vera is his
real name oh he's a fighter
cody barrett so what's special about
having a mullet that symbolizes freedom
confidence swagger hard work everything
right in america yeah in fact
what weight class is he
small guy 155 no if pour is 155 he has
to be a 45er huh is that the lowest
weight lowest 125.
in the male division
dustin who is the guy with the mullet
and uh pablito replied it's never how is
the guy
he's pretty he's a good foul that's
awesome
uh we had a couple more cats in the wild
uh
lots of theo today
someone saw theo evidently theo had a
baby
[Laughter]
but actually its head has the same it's
the same as eric's beard
babies are ugly when they come out man
yeah what size fitted captains would
wear one and a quarter
it's a small dog no what it uses
one of those snow cone
you just put a snow cone thing on it but
they haven't shaping it yet it must have
just came out of the and they look like
they had they had a natural pool birth
too
so he's like he's laying in his wife's
you know after and what you're supposed
to do is right right when the baby's
born just take your shirt off and the
dad and the baby connect by putting the
baby on your chest this could also be
the woman guys we don't know
everything in this day and age what's
the white stuff on the back what's that
white powder that's coke bro hopefully
well the head is flat enough to just
take a line right off that baby's head
this guy's all man [ __ ] you guys that's
my newborn son we're just kidding man
it's a [ __ ] comedy podcast yeah we
got you i'm sending a picture like this
then if you don't want to get clown
your flat baby ass hand
and you're gonna be mad at us
yeah
you knew that could be a fake baby too
man this could be it this look like an
insert this looks like a ghost babe
but but let's get back to the real facts
that looks like you it kind of does his
face his face dude that looks like both
of them
someone found brendan on tick-tock
before he really started hitting uh zoo
culture really hard
[Music]
oh my goodness and that's brandon corey
feldman
[Music]
oh that's dope oh wow nice tic tac
brandon yeah thank you
getting better at it but yeah that
facial hair is like exactly
same guy yeah it's clearly french
and then someone saw theo at a bj j
tournament after training with dustin
and actually yelled it out at him
the guy he yelled at him said he looks
like theo
we got theo vaughn here
on the bottom
[Laughter]
gang gang
[Laughter]
a lot of defense bro
how old's that kid theo you were beating
up or
oh that kid that took me
that kid probably anywhere from 12 to
15.
this this move though
he's in guards
he's just in guard he's just in guard
that's family's starting how do you win
a match how do you win that the guy with
the baby the guy at the bottom uh look
for submission
or the guy triangle or something you got
a pass yeah man get the half guard yeah
all right side control what else is
going on you wear shorts all the time
yeah i love you that's nice i like how
you have legs only on your calf what do
you mean you mean hair yeah yeah
legs
you have strong legs boy like strong
cricket oh
yeah baby i'm jackie chan
well he doesn't have a car so yeah
walking everywhere he got oh yeah he got
walking you see how it's only here below
the knee you know what i mean you don't
you just woke up like that you don't
shave that he's got no this is the legs
of a new york woman you know what i'm
saying
oh yeah you got them yeah they smooth it
look inside look at that that's all
muscle right here baby yeah
go ahead that's awesome go ahead go
ahead go ahead go ahead go ahead there
you go boom oh muscle
does bob have legs like that too yes
look at that
evil eyes
like you want to take me on the mat
you're scared about this yeah bob's the
same way same legs yeah well asians
don't get them from your mom well chin
show your legs aren't your legs don't
they i have no hair i have zero knee
brace over here agents don't have
asians don't you know chin you don't
have hair on your head
anywhere if you need hair where do you
get it from
what do you mean
oh what does that mean
yeah
i agree
chin you still rocking that knee brace
like john cena i took it off for today
because i'm trying to see how it feels
about it this guy is chin
[Music]
and he's got a really uh interesting
relationship advice question this is
chino
yo what up king of the sting it's your
boy tom out here in seattle washington
uh got relationship advice for you tom
my girl got offered slash ass to become
a surrogate for a gay couple okay now
we're getting into it
there is a financial incentive involved
about eleven hundred bucks per month
isn't that great for nine months
let me know what you guys think love the
show keep it up slang wang bus nuts so
ten thousand dollars basically ten
thousand dollars so what's the situation
here so the surrogate so his girl's
gonna have to get pregnant with somebody
else's baby as soon as that baby's born
she gives the baby up to this little gay
couple what the hell oh that depends on
the relationship with his with the girl
yeah i think i not i'm talking about
what's the relationship is it just
random people or no two married gay
couples i know but do they know them i'm
saying like what about you know you you
know yeah yeah yeah what's the incentive
though what's the incentive for him it'd
be money here's the problem though
depending on your girl's genetics you
know a lot of women have to have babies
it gets pretty sloppy
oh all right brendan
don't bounce back or some do it just
depends on the genetics
and also if it's not your kid and your
girl's gonna sacrifice their body and
all that [ __ ] i don't know yeah
he just said keep it tight keep it tight
if it's not tight afterwards get it
right
his girl might be a dying piece she
might bounce back yeah we need to see
the woman what you're better off
donating blood my man yeah
but that's not an option here man that
people want to have a child you can't
give them blood
how much money do there's 10 grand it
seems like it's just a one-time deal
thirteen and a half or something no no
it's nine months eleven hundred dollars
nine months nine months yeah i thought
they wanted that 12.
[Laughter]
she keeps that thing at that rate you
know me too i'm like hey this thing's
not coming out doug
yeah we gonna pay that cable bill
we need that 1100 honey yeah i don't
think that to me i don't think if if
it's purely financial i don't i don't
think that's enough money for what she's
putting herself through
is it the money plus expenses you know
it's like that you know what i mean or
all the expenses are coming out of that
1100.
you got to figure that out i need to i
need to know this 100 000 yeah if you
can understand drink during it i think
do it but if they want you to stay dry
as well that's stay dry no sushi no
caffeine that's an extra 800 if they
want you to stay dry
that's fair
so you're saying so you're saying 1900 a
month otherwise you have one of those
little eight ball bambinos like your old
dude had right there the other thing too
when that baby comes out it's gonna need
to suck on them titties for a little bit
so it's gonna be long because that's not
part of the deal though is it no no no
that ain't part of that you said
something i think you give him half a
quart when you pack you pack that in his
bag when you send his little ass home
baby you know
yeah um sting it hard sting yeah no man
i think it's the i think you'd have to
raise the amount of money brendan a lot
more
to what amount though eric how much
would it cost for somebody to get you to
do it if you're a woman i don't know man
like for your girl like what would you
do like you would let your girl do it
it wouldn't be for 1100
[Laughter]
hormones are jumping like crazy girl's a
dick right so i gotta deal with it now
how much so how much 50k a month 50k
who can who's going to do 50k a month i
mean cause the car doesn't what kim
kardashian had it was it 50km
that's a lot of money
50 i mean i'm ready to have her baby for
50k a month yeah
i'll figure it out yeah he looks like
brennan's dad a little bit
with him
i don't know what his dad looks i don't
even know what that means
i just mean a father like a parent yeah
well i have a parental wife
i know i mean but you also have a real
problem brendan
and the truth comes out bro are you
wearing spandex
your leg all right huh yeah yeah oh
y'all just got scared the other day i
thought i had a little stroke or
something bro we're at lunch and doing
pressure
out yeah you can't just just blood
circulation oh dude i thought you
mouthed the mouth oh bro i jumped on him
hopefully somebody
would film that that'd be yeah viral i
see i would do that for you that's cats
in the wild dude yeah
yeah can you guys send in pictures of a
theo and a brendan make it out
we need that we need that little
mouthful that's an erawan right there
who's this little timey uh she's got
another relationship advice question
okay but so would you all do it or not
i'm sorry to interrupt you
no absolutely not no pregnancy is a
beast you would do it you wouldn't let a
little butterfly carry a dang worm my my
sperm won't be able to do that you don't
have to do anything oh you're right if
my girl uh maybe for me if you were a
woman and you could carry it
would you charge questions if you're
just gonna be at home anyway chilling
yeah you can still play all those video
games and mess around with that black
man yeah and you but you're getting paid
your your screen name could be zygote
zygote7000
i'd have to think about it i have to
think about it what you think eric 15
g's a month
25.
jesus and scissor bros could cut the
chord at the end
no they no they wouldn't do that they
would drink the
all right yeah they would drink the
afterbirth you know
you guys would eat the placenta yeah gag
yeah we'd probably do a challenge
yeah yeah you're right here we could do
a challenge you're like guess what
my dad mailed us some of this
for sure would you let jeremiah carry
another man's baby oh yeah
yeah
it's a that's a tough one yeah i feel
the guy the guy the guy wasn't even
really talking about his own feelings
about it and that's important too yeah
at least he's asking though instead of
just making his wife do it some men i
think might make their wife's do it oh
yeah that's not right that would be
terrible
especially for 1100 yeah that she don't
even get all the money and she got to do
all the work oh well again 1100 after
tax yeah it's not a lot of money that's
just not a lot
well it depends on the relationship
that's what i'm saying is this her
cousin or you know what i mean it's just
like her people that you know she knows
or like really good friends gay uncles
something yeah but wouldn't that make
the baby strange though because she you
know yeah if they do the mom's always
hanging around no
if the dude is somebody they know it
might be different that's what i'm
saying
yeah it's a handy cat dude or something
you might never have a child
you want to help him out
i've heard he could really mess up the
woman psychologically too because she
has to give up her baby because she
bonds with that baby
she's just a little orphan maker dude a
friend of mine uh had donated sperm and
then they hit him with that document
when he's like 40 years old or 30 years
old that said you have like 27 children
yes whoa wow that was a movie about that
delivery man yeah he had like a thousand
kids right yeah
how much [ __ ] was he he's none
of it seven is alive you say there's
nothing all right oh you wanna be i'm
sorry doctor dr vaughn over here well
i'm just saying dude
girl you're about to get all this in
yeah he's like i'm a navy man
oh this
is about to get this little butterfly
dog
this battleship hey theo hey brendan
it's sarah coming at you from british
columbia canada and i've got a debate
club for you boys
so
when you break up with someone
do you delete everything off your
instagram and your facebook and just
wipe it clean
or
do you leave the pictures on there
and just kind of let it be
how it is like it was the past but it's
fine me personally
i get rid of that trash and make room
for the future yeah let me know what you
guys think okay buzz buzz you delete all
that [ __ ] forget about that
no no
first of all you're talking about
you're talking about years of stuff
though yeah [ __ ] him it's like 10 10 how
long has this been going on instagram's
like 10 years old now or something like
that
and what if it's in zest what if it's a
family member you know what it just says
about him that he is just a jealous
possessive [ __ ] right here
but he on this girl's instagram like
this he's just scrolling
hell yeah man get rid of that [ __ ] you
gotta get rid of it they made it easier
especially a young lady like this yeah
send out the bad signal if they made it
easier you started posting those thought
pics by the beach and the thong yeah
it's too much to do no no she's saying
when you're in a new relationship
do you like you know like so now you get
into a new relationship do you get rid
of everything from the past oh that's
what i'm saying so let's say she broke
up and she don't do nothing on instagram
yeah she want to do four years right she
they break up and now she's dating a new
dude and then what is it a nice guy
that's a lot of work they don't make it
easy if it was like delete all we'd be
good oh she's single look at her she
very intentionally left her instagram
handle on her submission video so i
think that's the green light yeah yeah
she might want to meet a man take it
easy man well let's can we like oh the
count is private
we can't even look at you know oh
now we can't even see what's going on
tell by that avatar though
yeah she's looking that's a risky move
judging by avatar is that it look at her
there she's a good
lady and she's fit look at her
look at her body man on the beach she's
fit
well i mean she the lady last week she
gonna be with some knucklehead who's
gonna be scrolling like hey why you
still still got me yeah he's gonna
investigate why you got a picture of
this dude still wow we went together
four years and bubble bugs well it
depends who you're with too like if
you're with some famous actor athlete or
something like that dude joe schmo at
ups i'm like what the
yeah but somebody [ __ ] michael b
jordan but somebody that's like that
that you'll notice a lot of like
instagram type chicks
they don't ever put pictures of their
boyfriends on there because it's bad for
business yeah mm-hmm you know but if
she's just a regular child she's just
some normal chick and she was like oh i
loved him i mean it depends on you know
yeah that's just a lot of work it's a
lot of it's a lot of work to be like
okay delete it so the real question is
should you be putting your relationship
on the internet that's the real question
huh
it's tough i don't know
yeah
this guy needs some help
you would erase all the you know because
that's like her dating profile right
kinda if she wants to meet another guy
yeah basically her dating profile she
have she has to get rid of the other
things that you should delete like you
know i i had this issue when i first you
know we got serious now let's talk and
then you're talking about like you know
you you're still on tinder ryan all this
stuff right yeah you can't just delete
those apps right that's another thing
you can't just remove yourself like this
it'll take some time it takes some time
wait should i erase your tinder profile
yeah man you can't just with your girl
like why are you on riot yeah then i'm
like why you why you on there yeah what
are you trying to do
so it was a whole thing but i told her i
was like because you have a subscription
and it runs out in three months and then
you're still there but i'm not on it
it's not on my phone three months left
yeah they leave you out there though
some of you out here in the wild last
these these apps will leave you around
the world you're out there in the wild
so that's why are you on any uh oh no i
learned my lesson i already told you
that i got scammed
you did you met up with a man
no i got scammed by a russian
and she's like oh you're sending money
yeah no yeah the ukraine whatever you
send them some money no i don't have i
mean they're like hey my my
grandfather's gonna move in next month
that's the exception
let's get back out there bro no i'm okay
man i like being alone i got my black
butt i got my toys i'm okay you can't be
friends i knew he was still [ __ ] the
black people knew it
was this whole thing every time he
passed the clock she's like i hear you
in there [ __ ]
[Laughter]
calling me what you say
oh
what would you do you think with an app
or you mean this situation yeah that
situation yeah you know i think about
the other my girlfriend is on my youtube
she's on my instagram she's on
everything and i'm doing comments and
[ __ ] dude she does that's not helpful
yeah i do i don't like that that's not
good i've had my girl on my podcast like
that's what i'm saying like what we
break up for some strange reason then oh
you have to delete the videos like you
know then the new people were just
possessive and insecure your girls
reading the
she's in my youtube videos she's in my
yeah i put on like we go camping i put
but i think about that all the time like
if we break up and we have good and bad
times and i'm thinking like oh crap what
do i do now so do people out i already
did it do people ask you ask her about
your criminal past did that ever come up
i'm not a criminal i didn't do anything
people around instagram i'm not seeing
her on the internet yeah no no not she's
not recently she's she's right she's
right there
which one which one i did that like
seven times two the one in the all the
group the whole group whoops well that's
a lot of people in that but i'm holding
her oh okay
i've always kept a relationship off yeah
there's so many people though i've
always kept relationship off my mind
yeah it's not be the thing yeah that's
what i think on my instagram look at her
right there she's in the previous ones
too
yeah okay i don't want nobody knowing
that you actually even let me sit in
front of you she's on my youtube channel
if it's a boy
[Laughter]
that's our friend dusty sorry dusty yeah
it's all right guys you got a big
angry angry birds character
dusty knows about that yeah
[Laughter]
he's got that baby doppler on him baby
that's the doppler he got that
job
i'm in the chopper like i'm in the
chopper dusty's head is just tilted to
the left looks like a oh dusty out there
vibing with them clowns
[Laughter]
that's what i thought dusty was on the
left next to um
little bobby
bobby too
that's kim that's a that's a girl man
well a girl can also be someone that has
um that looks like that okay
i'm just saying if it's the headbutt
contest i know you're talking about
now those little kids can headbutt in a
lot of asian countries have you seen
some of that videography no
someone that's behind a paper i watched
a russian slap contest the other night
on youtube the power of it
what's that all about they just be
slapping the best out of each other yeah
they don't subtitles everything they
don't care that's a thing they're
willing to do anything
i had no idea they're willing they don't
have as many feelings as we have man oh
there's competitions yeah when you're
living in a cold ass place
feelings is definitely not something
yeah you got to go to a restaurant to
get them yeah no one has time no this is
it right that's an appetizer that is not
keto oh so there's a competition
look at this big yeah i could use him
for angry birds
look at this [ __ ] look at that guy's
arms bro
boom oh yeah
i use his wrist his wrist yeah they're
trying
let's see he pops up oh he's unconscious
but he's up how do you win this huh
whoever just like that
that's how you win
that's all we've got foreign
rules this is so russian that's
disqualification man no it's russia dude
does that guy have those silicon yeah he
has fake his arms oh my god they're
filled with oil people put oil in their
muscles so gross jesus christ this is
like a
family reunion right
that does look like your brother dude
and this is just a female side
your brother must be making 1100 an arm
right
see but they hit but behind the air so
it knocked your equilibrium yeah the
whole thing is insane it should only be
able to hit in the face
oh he took that daddy okay he took now
he's scared this kid's a lot [ __ ] yeah
yeah
i'm out at that point yeah like all
right you win man
this guy there's a whole leaf this guy's
obviously and he's tough at macaroni
grill wherever he usually waits at
because tony roma's oh
oh and they just kept doing it and then
they come at the end
sorry semen
they see men at the end that's how you
say it damn well who won this one that
is he you wouldn't
slapping the [ __ ] at each other i'm
siemens
you would make it exciting for everybody
that'd be a good challenge man yeah what
happens did they win do it on scissor
bro yeah
is that is that ray romano in the back
yeah yeah i don't think you guys don't
do that one young raven yeah it is i
don't know if you guys read it or not
but
there is um
the new thing people are doing is not
ejaculating during sex man oh that's
that's that in sales [ __ ] bro you need
to stay off reddit
is there a term for that that's a real
no not november no we're in fights
no fap when we're in [ __ ] but people
want to hold their careers they want to
hold their charisma or whatever chi
[Laughter]
thank yeah i'm not crazy
a good call oh he looks exactly
way better looking over the years
all right that's what happens with dudes
they want to hold their charisma you
guys do it
would you guys do it hell no what's the
point i get that's the point of that
what are you talking about yeah that's
pulling your nut yeah
that's you the girl like
i've done it before for like two months
it's called sexual sexual transmutation
yeah yeah and what happened you know
your testosterone lowers when you do
that well i read something where it
makes you more productive more focused
more energy all that stuff so that's why
i tried it and what'd you feel at the
end brother i just what dude living in
his mom's basement wrote
no so neil strauss an author actually
talked about it so i started reading
online about it yeah and they're
supposed to make it look uh the game the
game yeah which i think i love the game
and did um which is just a communication
book and
yeah it's all sociology with
manipulation yes and it works it
actually works
it doesn't always work not always but it
actually works though i told a girl that
was the last dress she ever should have
worn tonight and her cousin came and
[ __ ] punched me
her cousin came in
he's from where he's from it could have
been her husband
that's the theme of that book though you
put them down at first to get their
attention yeah it's like you look like
[ __ ] girl and she's like oh you crazy
tell them they look like they have one
lip or that you know that their outfit
doesn't fit or or are you supposed to
find like
the the ugliest one in the group and
that's the one
hey you look beautiful the hot ones are
going to go like this oh thank you not
you i'm just talking about you i was
telling you your big ass friend yeah
yeah if you say damn little angry bird
with that freaking
oh that works in i don't know i i don't
know man
i suggest just being nice and not
reading a book no no but i'm saying
there is something to like look if you
took a regular communication book okay
and you read the things in a
communication but how to communicate
with people like tom sawyer
we'll just say the book no but there's
like there's plenty of them it's not a
secret i have one in my audiobook it's
like i forgot the one that's like how to
communicate and get what you want oh a
book about communication i'm saying like
a regular book about communication that
you read these things and there are good
tips about communicating in business and
life and dating too then but but what
i'm saying is what these other people
have done is they've taken those same
concepts yeah but their intention it's
all about intentions yeah this is a
great one i have that one
friends and influence people ted bundy
also read those books i know but what
i'm saying that's what i'm saying it's
just a tool and the people that make
these manipulation books are towards
women they take these same concepts but
it it it's it's just all about intention
is what i'm saying okay
do you believe that do you believe
that it can work that if you uh
if you do some of the stuff the man said
in the book that it could be good yeah
jen said it worked for him give us some
examples yeah give us some examples well
it's like when you want something
if you want something the first thing
you need to do is find out what the
other person wants first in a situation
and then what hide it in the house
yeah how do you find that stuff
how do you do that no no but it's just
we're not talking about like i'm talking
about getting chicks oh man
that's what the book's for yeah
no but when i went clubbing when i went
to bars and stuff i i it's the main
thing is you actually have confidence to
go up to girls yeah yeah the main thing
is just going up to girls no one does
that it's really intimidating so when
you have that in your back pocket you're
able to talk to people whatever i don't
know what you're saying
the first rule was like if you want to
get a girl talk to a girl yeah yeah or
even bring a girlfriend out there listen
man huh you got to go [ __ ] boys out
there the ones that get a lot of chicks
they get rejected more times than
regular guys
right right right i understand yeah it's
all about a numbers game
hey you want to get with me no i'll [ __ ]
you damn what's up with you yeah you're
fine what's up with you man that [ __ ]
that's what happens what's up with you
then one goes i'll be with you and he's
like i still got it yeah yeah that's a
number that's like it's a number but
like regular dudes are so shy and white
dude you could just say white dude
black jews are way more confident than
women i think you'd be surprised you
think so i think i don't know i don't
know enough i don't know
i don't know everyone's got insecurities
yeah everyone's insecure
you get girls mainly yeah if you do
start i'm taking a break i'm just
working on myself man i know yeah yeah
how much time you got
uh i don't know about him i think how
long you been sober
12 years sober but as far as that yeah
just working on myself he's trying to
lay off that yum-yum making that young i
will say steve i feel like you are
happier
i feel like you are
you you seem to be like more confident
you seem to be more and i i i do feel
that friendly i do feel that man keeps
going i love it keep going
yeah this is you're it's like a better
view right now vibrance
yeah man i gotta work on myself you know
what i mean your skin's popping yeah
hair popping yeah yeah you look legs
strong as hell yeah i feel good yeah
good for you look any age
he could be 22 or 67 or 40 something
yeah oh yeah
but you are 40 something that's worse
but i didn't see i didn't know stevie
prior to this i've been on stevie for
like yeah week six this year yeah i've
only known him this way so i was like oh
yeah this d was a mess
back
yeah you see him hiding coke and pill
i love it today it sounds funny actually
just noticed it i should read that but
anyway communication is important
communication is key and how to
communicate is very important i'll give
you one little tip
there we go let's get into it
so this is if you're at a bar or any
club or anywhere in a bookstore find
something interesting on a girl that you
think is cute uh go so would you get
this whole thing out it's my little
sister's birthday next week i want to
get her something cute boom something
that started something like she thinks
oh you have a little sister you carry a
little sister something like that or go
up there but man smells like farting
she goes why am i somebody farted you
believe that boom combo starter
that stuff like that works too ten
simple rules it's funny in the chat we
need to be shopping
by far we need to make sure this girl is
okay
this might be that like she's been
kidnapped for 10 years
yeah she can't leave the house i can't
try that try that
food show up to girlfriends man like
farting her see if she doesn't laugh i
don't think
no one's going to the shop seminar yeah
what are some other shop rules of dating
[Laughter]
welcome to my seminar
it's just lonely we got special guest
speaker brian calling tonight
[ __ ] he's like
but dude yeah but uh
i'm trying to think of what you what's
some other good shot thing oh what you
doing in my trunk [ __ ]
that would be something with you yeah
yeah
stop making noise back here
bro that's a combo star
[Laughter]
no idea like i said i'm trying to no he
walked up to a girl measure out yeah
yeah you look like you fit in the trunk
you know it's two for one foot long i'd
say that too oh my god who don't love a
sub huh i'm just talking about subs here
yeah
this guy needs some help being the best
man okay all right all right we'll see
what we can do
his old pretty ass eyes
chin
sam and knuckle i need a little advice
guys my brother's getting married i'm
the best man which means i got that best
man's speech amen brother hold the fort
down for a couple minutes you know
though a little comedy in the speech a
little heartfelt
bring it back all together for that last
big bang
i need i need some help on it fellas
gang gang plays buzz
half
what i did that's my brother's best man
you just have bullet points to riff off
of but you don't want to just read what
you wrote in the hotel room before you
have some bullet points so you can riff
on a little bit
[Music]
well it points to riff on all you have
to do is see from the moment
keeping somebody in the trunk of her car
your freaking sex traffic brandon used
to you did that what you kept a girl in
your truck yeah don't listen to theo man
but he did used to get food from butcher
box facts
still do butcher boxes
he's gonna be able to say too much yeah
sorry man i i've really took a
conversation in the wrong direction
there what do you think guys would do
from his heart that's it yeah what would
you do eric yeah that's not yeah exactly
steve just from his heart that's it what
are some spiders
no maybe it's not good to have a plan
maybe he's just going to say bullet
points
you can still look down and see the
bullet that's conjecture man uh yeah
that might work i think keep it short
and sweet yeah you know don't make it
about you you know remember remember
this it's the bride's day
so you know keep it fun i mean it's hard
like where comics are getting married
i'd light up her dad have some fun with
it roast the dab the thick ass mom
that'll be a sec
his second showtime special will be that
bullet points at weddings
[Applause]
does it smell like fart in here
we kept the cake yet
and again he's got one of those janet
jackson
little browsers performing
um i think you gotta have a time limit
though one thing that gets weird is when
it gets too long yeah ten minutes is
good ten minutes
on stage well hold on dude
so much more time history man
so we have thousands of years of history
to look back on 10 minutes nothing five
minutes a hot three minutes goes a long
way that is hot that's even hot i say 90
seconds or less bro 97 really at a
wedding dude at a wedding
give me two minutes 90 seconds is a long
time this is his brother that's it has
to mean something i think you can mean
something in 90 seconds nick what do you
think yeah uh i i think keep it short
and sweet uh
you got to think about the people who
are there at the wedding they're it's
for they don't want to be there yeah
yeah yeah
no one wants to be anybody
half of them want to be also divorced
yeah
all right one minute acknowledge that
yeah one minute that's it now that's a
great thing
i'm sure there's a lot of people in here
that want to be divorced right now no
please don't sure a lot of you went
through this you don't bring up bad [ __ ]
at a wedding yeah that's like somebody
going into surgery and you talk about
how many times people die in surgery
nobody should do is acknowledge like you
know i'll probably be doing this more
than once the odds are 53 of people get
divorced yeah please don't that's not
terrible
it's gotten bad out there man people are
you know in surgery
surgery they put x on your body parts
they're not supposed to cut off you know
oh jeez that's not good nobody's paying
attention
so a minute guys a minute and a half
okay okay
the man is obviously need some help man
talk about the past talk about how he's
proud of him talk about how gorgeous
yeah
no i don't think you dropped that how
gorgeous the bride is yeah you got to
keep well you don't got me you don't you
don't want to be like this your bride
fine as hell
you lucky as hell
you got to do it before me but anyway
right yeah don't do that
my sister gave my favorite speech i've
ever heard for my other sister she
talked about how she was
really protective over her older sister
and she didn't trust the guy right away
but the moment she knew was when they
were out on the beach and my sister was
in like three foot of water and she
tripped over and uh her now husband dove
in with his clothes on to try to save
her in three three feet of water and she
killed crushed and it was very short
well first of all
first of all that was low stakes he knew
was only three
i don't want to hear it he jumped jack
yeah he jumped in with tommy bahama
shirt
yeah it's all a sham
that's a good question if your wife
falls over on a ship because on a ship
the only thing they can do is go in a
big circle to get back to where the
person fell off that's the fastest way
the ship can get does it does it happen
through on those ships like you've been
on cruise ships right you got your
degree on yeah cruise ship yeah and
people fall off sometimes and sometimes
they get back around to them and
sometimes they don't semester at sea
yeah sometimes they get back around to
them and somehow they don't oh right
they just keep going then you're stuck
in the middle of the door no they come
back but sometimes that people they you
know they can't find them well you're
supposed to throw i heard this on the
thief supposed to throw a thing out
there yeah you're supposed to point
you're supposed to keep pointing yeah
the tough part is at night and sometimes
even if you're pointing for a little
while you'll check your phone you forget
you're pointing you get a text yeah
that's a rude [ __ ] right there
the dog it's like this if you go like
this oh [ __ ] the crate challenge
you know i mean scrape towels popping
yeah yeah don't do the crate challenge
on a cruise ship but you know that [ __ ]
could get yeah it's hard to point at
something for a long time man even if
you love it yeah even if you love it
that'd be a horrible way to die yeah
horrible you know you just be thinking
imagine being out there you're just
thinking about sharks sharks that's all
you're thinking about anytime you see
the ocean you think of sharks that's why
he ain't [ __ ] he jumped in that three
feet of water like i got you
jumped into the pond
but yeah i found out it was a kitty
watch yeah
four kids later it worked it worked
that's true yeah
what you got uh we closed it out with
maybe a cat's confession i think stevie
might have some thoughts on this one
it's uh it's pretty good
what'd you think steve
oh i didn't play yet sorry hi boys my
anonymous confession is that i'm trying
to stand out at work and show my bosses
at this new job that i am worth
investing in so when they assumed that i
was part asian and wanted me to be part
of their ad campaign i didn't correct
anyone in telling them that i actually
just look
that way but i'm fully caucasian now i
just have to pretend for as long as i
work here that i am a hacker and i'm not
and that's a terrible thing
now she got to wear a ghee to work
yeah
you know what i mean yeah she got a
brick she got to bring a karaoke machine
she sounds so white too i can't imagine
i
it says more about them well they might
be worried to bring it up yeah you know
what i'm saying is she asian
yeah they're all stupid they're like
karen don't see me
she's not correcting us
yeah they don't want yeah that we live
in a such a pc society right no one
wants to talk they're scared to say are
you asian yeah and then she's like i
don't want to tell them so it's like
yeah they're all you're all she's got to
say something though everybody she's
gonna have to go to work and just put up
this act but is it an act or is it
people just evading her and not even
afraid of of saying of you know maybe
she'll get like some special gifts or
something
makes you like rachel
a lot of asian josiah have like a little
bowl of mints by the desk or something
when does this happen people keep
bringing her kimchi and [ __ ] every
monday and she's like god i don't need
this [ __ ] you know what i'm talking
about help us out here yeah but what
kind of do you think she even
this confession is nonsense i gotta say
something it's not it's not buying it
i'm just saying it says more about her
it says a lot about where she works yeah
it says more about that it says worry
about their co-workers
why don't she you know and also her
worth being like what what is she
getting and advancing in her career
because she's campfire
yeah
oh
that can't find an asian these days yeah
molly brown baby right there
that's it right there we need more asian
yeah well maybe don't say anything then
i guess i don't know you should chill
out in the term half or i don't know if
that's yeah yeah people don't say that
yeah
i'm a halfer it's half up okay there's
nothing wrong with being half no there's
not but you don't go around saying i'm a
halfer dude
i never even talk about it
theo's only want to talk about it yeah
he's only brings it up do you feel
sometimes your white or black side flare
up
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
no i just i don't even think about it
i just i don't even i just never i'm not
like i'm not one of those comics that go
on stage and be like you know somehow
this and have that so now i can
you know i could steal from a thing and
do this i just never talk about it
because i always say people want to know
what you are so they can know how to
hate you do you ever use the n-word dick
um yeah we're my friends yeah baby
[Laughter]
you know you're not getting not getting
it take it easy
take it easy
see he's one of these comfortable white
people yeah
i remember i remember you know what's
funny because i remember doing his
podcast and it was afterwards he was
just chilling and talking with him and
just he dropped one
oh really yeah and then he caught
himself was like oh [ __ ]
he's like yeah yeah cool with you
he gave me that look and i just like
okay you know what i'm not even gonna
live in a he i know i know when the rap
song is on in phil's car yeah
because hard you know what's going on in
his car
he remixes it with the er though look
man i you know i don't know exactly what
you guys are talking about
[Laughter]
but
i mean it's it is what it is out there
baby anyways man everybody's doing their
best this this this is a weird situation
and yeah it says more about her it says
a lot about where she works yeah and all
that stuff yeah
but you know they don't know and i think
maybe what if they think she is asian
and they're trying to be supportive or
scared but i think they're scared in
this in this society
there's nothing wrong with that you
could ask it depends where she's at
though if they're like impossible
you're right what state are they in yeah
they're like ah we don't want to mess
with them i keep bringing a cup of
noodles they keep bringing their pokemon
cards but if they're legitimately like
sriracha not even asian [ __ ] what
campaign would they even
be doing that they go we need an asian
for this like what is that meeting she
just came then i guess we had to hire
her man we know she was already working
there they were having a meeting and
they were like sorry we're gonna do this
thing i think we want to outreach to
more asian people what should we do
she's like i'll do it let's get bethany
who's not even an asian name probably
you know
her
a lot of asian people get susie joy
yeah joy is one yeah also known as yours
but you know by the last name it'll be
like joy leaf right or change kim yeah
this chick show like her name is like
you know barbie barbie you know what i
mean yeah ricky ricky is one
ricky
no that's more latino deal especially
you said it
ricky
yeah you're right no it's not
yeah so i don't i don't know about that
this whole that's a tough one but that
whole thing sounds ridiculous to me yeah
that's it that's another good one
uh
sunny
sunny sunny as one
oh sunny i don't know any sunny day
sunny is a popular asian name isn't it
chin yeah i heard it many times yep see
i don't know dave one question yeah
david
david yeah david
they're real but by the way it's never
their real name like steve what's your
real name sam
kwong woo that's your real name
reason i just changed it to change
change
because it happened it wasn't texas my
friends couldn't say jin they were
waiting live that's why he changed his
name you gotta go uh yeah bob has a
career name too he's
songwood next time
they made asian people change their name
because it made other people
uncomfortable
but steven who decided
to be in their parents still was a
teacher like this
you're
a lot of them do that before the
american school system who gives them
the name do somebody give it or they my
mom and dad probably there you go yeah
and what's your mom and dad's name uh my
mom
it used to be chung-ja but she changed
it to genie generally
yeah
and then what's your pops
uh what was your name no i don't i
didn't know i don't remember his korean
dumb robert these are names they won't
even having the name if you're never
going to use it or remember and then do
your do your parents call you by you
yeah yeah yeah so if my mom was talking
to bob she'd go
did you have to have an official name
change
i don't know it's just what what is it
we did it when we were naturalized but
yeah but we all call each other the same
chin and my brother's name is jongsu
and of course we got made fun of way
more with chin and chong yeah yeah
that's too easy do they make you strip
naked at the naturalizing place or not
yeah
do they make is it like at the
naturalized place do they make you strip
they didn't make a stripper
we used to do that thing where we would
make a sound and see and ask asian
people if it's a means something in
nature that's racist yeah people did
that though
you know they did do that
they would do that what does that mean
yeah did i say something like wow near
my brother's name is your real name eric
griffin yeah
no it's teddy
well you know some hollywood people no
no no what's your real name why would i
change my name frank that don't sound
hollywood eric griffin don't sound house
but it could be short for something
error
[Laughter]
lsu has a new a football player that is
a craziest the washer huh lawasha no oh
no
dakotas
the coldest yeah and he's super baller
yeah
there was a thing going around on world
star this mom named the two twins
lawasha la draya
oh really hold this that's what it is
pork chop you laugh too hard at that
well that's why
you know what that is she didn't like
their father
yeah
didn't
not
athletes now can get
sponsorships now
endorsement that should be dude for sure
absolutely still we're doing our show
we go to louisiana
get the coldest man and know this ice
cream
who else can we get king of the sting
the coldest ice cream yeah we just did
it you could have a bunch of products
anti-freeze
air conditioning we're not trying to
slang ac units but antifreeze man you
gotta make more profit on an antifreeze
bucket of antifreeze now you make so
much more money on ice cream that's it's
cheap bro yeah how does that even equate
that sense that when you think about
that because ice cream's cheap
like the the markup's insane on ice yeah
yeah it could be but you can't sell that
much ice creams to people the [ __ ] we
can't the coldest yeah
they're gonna get that at the safeway
i'm in la jolla this weekend thursday
friday saturday comedy store la jolla
kids and the next the two weeks after
that i'm in uh san jose san jose improv
september 9th through the 11th second
through the fourth i'm at caroline's in
new york great clowns then i'm at the
next weekend oh my mom's going to come
she said oh yeah that's my hometown i
like when your mom comes
down bro me and jeremiah are going to be
in austin we're doing
some kind of comedy thing movie tower
festival yeah we're doing the moon tower
festival for you look at you out here
get i don't know where you get tickets
but check it out i've never been to
texas moon tower tower festival
youtube.com that'd be fun man congrats
to be doing the damn thing yeah and i'll
be in la jolla next week in the weekend
after you oh fun man and um yep that's
it that's what i got all right kids love
you amen baby
brendan and theo fighter and weight i
got to go in and go hard in the paint i
do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn hungry
like i'm fresh off keto seeing red like
andrew santino every song i hit like the
great bambino burning ain't the queso
and the quesoritos but everything's
gonna be fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude got a
pack of matches in his pockets at all
times they sliding into my dms a couple
of you tried but couldn't beat them quit
playing like nintendo ds you don't want
the smoke like joey diaz meaning y'all
edible just got my eyebrows threaded and
i'm feeling incredible brandon's son hit
me up he said it's too loud in the club
can you pick me up
king and a sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you